her love of flowers has brought grace
nia chai a long way
today she's the proud owner of a flower
farm in the town of fika
near the kenyan capital nairobi it's a
certified fair trade company with more
than 500 employees
together they grow 20 different
varieties of rows
the reason that there is process and we
have flowers on this farm
it's because of my love for flowers long
before
even bought this farm you know even if a
coffee could
probably somebody would say that it is a
better business than flowers
for me it is very it was very important
that i worked with a product
that i liked myself i was happy
her nearly 30 hectares of land are
covered with greenhouses full of roses
all of the flowers are grown without the
use of chemicals
once harvested the roses are packed and
placed in a cold store
ready to be sent to europe both the cold
store and the artificial lighting use a
lot of electricity
but the power supply isn't always
reliable in kenya
and power cuts are frequent
grace nia chai has often had to decide
whether to keep the flowers fresh
using a diesel generator which is costly
or to let the roses die
so for years she's looked for
alternatives
renewable energy sources like solar
power were always very expensive
but last year she got a solar system
that offers up to 150 kilowatts of power
financed with the help of a german
startup called ecolego
they came first of all to educate us
about the benefits of
solar energy and along the way
we they also showed us that it was
possible
for us to start with the just a few
steps
and get to a place where we can be have
a solar energy
she now pays around 2 400 euros a month
to the startup
it's a lot of money but still around 30
percent less than she used to pay for
electricity
after nine years the system will be paid
off and she'll only need to finance the
maintenance costs
ecolego serves a number of businesses in
kenya
including another flower company called
rift valley roses
here they've set up a floating solar
system
eco league co-founder martin bott has
come from germany to inspect the
installation
he's worked with solar power for 16
years and swears by it
companies that use it to reduce their
energy bills are actually saving a lot
of money
secondly it's also saving co2 emissions
and helping us to save the planet
the firm already has rooftop solar
panels from ecolego
but more electricity was needed as they
had no land free for a second solar
system
the owners came up with the idea of
using their farm reservoir
from which they irrigate the roses it's
kenya's first floating solar system
it was set up by technician ali prubai
he's installed a number of solar systems
for eco ligo since the
project first began in 2017
but this here was quite different
well the floating system has a lot of
different issues
compared to a land mounted system as you
know it has to be
corrosive resistance you have to now
understand how to move things because
you're talking about something that
floats
and we don't know any of these items so
we had to rely deeply on the knowledge
of
the technical team at ecolego
the startup now operates in six
countries ecolego has an unusual funding
policy
to push forward its energy revolution
because bank loans are usually slow to
come through
the company operates only with
crowdfunding the money comes directly
from private investors
individuals or families crowd investing
has a few advantages
it's flexible it's fast and it helps
people to
actively do something against the
climate crisis
by using their capital for sustainable
energy projects like this
especially the fact that it's fast and
flexible
helps us to use it for these kind of
projects
the investment has definitely paid off
for grace nia chai
and it's encouraged her to keep aiming
higher
in the future we can only hope that
there will be less power cuts
but i am as a farm is that we may get to
a place where we will be
100 particularly with a
major usage of power that will be
maximum using sora
that would take her one step closer to
her ultimate goal
to sell flowers that are not only fair
trade
but also grown on a farm that's
completely climate neutral
you